[Musique]
avec vos reines frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline à la une de la
presse les réactions aux attaques
lancées hier par la Russie contre
plusieurs villes ukrainiennes des
bombardements présentés par le Kremlin
comme des représailles après l'explosion
du pont de Crimée c'était le weekend
dernier mais la décision de blédir
Poutine de bombarder des infrastructures
civiles à travers toute l'Ukraine
provoque l'indignation de la presse
internationale et notamment de la presse
française la croix dénonce ce matin le
choix de la terreur du patron du Kremlin
avec cette photo de civil au milieu des
décombres de leur maison c'est à
sloviance que dans la région de donest
que dans l'est du pays une stratégie de
la terreur que dénonce également
libération qui évoque un cran
supplémentaire dans la fuite en avant
meurtrière de Vladimir Poutine cette
fois la victime est une habitante de
Kiev on le voit elle est blessée à la
tête et cette photo rappelle les débuts
de l'invasion russe en Ukraine en
février dernier suite en avant répète le
Figaro qui a retenu pour ça une cette
photo de véhicule incendiés à Kiev
toujours hier le résultat de la
vengeance du président russe l'horreur
de Poutine titre Il Manifesto cette fois
il s'agit d'un immeuble totalement
détruit dans la capitale toujours le
quotidien italien fait état de la
réaction de l'ONU de l'UE et de l'OTAN
qui parle d'une nouvelle escalade
inacceptable je cite de la guerre la
communauté internationale que le
président Vladimir veut le direlinsky a
appelé de nouveau à l'aide hier après
c'est bombardements un appel on le voit
relayé par le quotidien britannique de
Guardian qui cite aussi la réaction
d'Emmanuel Macron le président français
s'alarme je le cite d'un profond
changement dans la nature du conflit en
Ukraine une indignation Hélène dont se
font l'écho des dessinateurs de presse à
travers le monde dans le dessin d'Anne
tilness
dans la presse française à présent les
pénuries d'essence Hélène qui frappent
les stations services de l'Hexagone on
en parlé à l'instant dans le journal
mais la chasse au plats fait toujours la
une ce matin des quotidiens nationaux et
locaux dont Midi Libre qui évoque des
files d'attente interminables alors que
le mouvement de grève on l'a dit dans
plusieurs raffineries et des pots de
carburant vient d'être reconduits pour
des augmentations de salaire prenant en
compte à la fois l'inflation et les
profits exceptionnels réalisés par les
groupes pétroliers le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France voit les Français
prise au piège et ils s'inquiète de voir
grandir s'agrandir la fracture sociale
entre les habitants des grandes villes
et ceux des zones rurales plus impactées
selon lui par ses pénuries le journal
estime je le cite que les torts sont
partagés entre le gouvernement les
syndicats et les groupes pétroliers le
gouvernement que l'opinion lui trouve
surpris par cette crise actuelle dont il
redoute qu'elle puisse réactiver le
réflexe gilet jaune le grand mouvement
social de l'automne 2018 l'opinion de
cake ou le dessin l'opinion le dessin de
cake en loi montre deux automobilistes
dans une file d'attente à la station
essence les Russes bombardent à nouveau
Kiev ils ont de l'essence pour leurs
avions eux on a connu caca plus inspiré
en ne se quitte pas là-dessus Hélène on
ne se quitte pas là dessus et histoire
de vous changer un peu les idées
pollines quoique je vous propose de
jeter un style à courrier internationale
qui donc fait état d'une affaire
surprenante j'en perd mon latin on a
évoqué ici les tricheries présumées qui
touchent le monde feutré des échecs et
figurez-vous que le problème touche
aussi les danses traditionnelles
irlandaises c'est pointu selon The Irish
independent les concours seraient
gangrenés par la triche au point que le
vice-Premier ministre irlandais a mis en
garde contre je le cite une dégradation
de l'image de tout le pays on ne badine
pas avec le folklore
et on me badine pas non plus avec la
mode d'ailleurs le pose vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure rapporte que le
créateur de mode français Jean-Paul
Gaultier se retrouve poursuivi pour
avoir copié la célèbre Vénus de
Botticelli la Galerie des Offices de
Florence qui concerne le précieux
tableau en effet illégitime ses
vêtements la Vénus de Botticelli on le
rappelle représente la déesse sortant
des eaux recouvrant sa nudité de sa
longue chevelure bronde ou blonde elle
me fait un peu penser à vous Pauline ah
bon moins habillée bien sûr c'est gentil
merci beaucoup hé